es momento de hablar de economía en
france24 y por ello me acompaña en el
estudio daniela blandón daniela muy
buenas noches bienvenida iniciamos en
venezuela que comenzó a aplicar aumentos
progresivos en las tarifas de servicios
públicos valentina muy buenas noches
pues el metro de caracas era gratuito
desde 2019 sin embargo comenzó desde
este lunes a cobrar 20 mil bolívares o
lo equivalente a 0,01 centavos de dólar
por cada viaje es decir un dólar
alcanzará para pagar alrededor de 100
boletos esto hace parte de un plan
gubernamental de alza progresiva de las
tarifas en algunos de los servicios
públicos algunos de los cuales son
gratuitos desde hace años el presidente
nicolás maduro dijo que luego vendrá el
aumento del resto del sistema de
transporte y también en otros servicios
el pueblo quiere que mejoren los
servicios públicos pero el pueblo está
dispuesto a pagar sus servicios públicos
y nosotros apoyamos al pueblo con el
sistema patria y además las tarifas de
los servicios públicos en venezuela son
absolutamente solidaria daniela y vamos
a argentina porque el presidente alberto
fernández va a impulsar una
investigación criminal contra su
antecesor por desvío de recursos
valentina en 2018 del entonces
presidente mauricio macri obtuvo un cupo
de crédito del fondo monetario
internacional por 56 mil millones de
dólares de ese total se alcanzaron a
desembolsar unos 44 mil millones ahora
el gobierno de alberto fernández está
intentando renegociar esa creencia pero
sé que deja de que su antecesor tomó
este dinero prestado en busca de su
reelección y que lo que hizo fue generar
una gran fuga de divisas y a su vez
desestabilizar la moneda
he instruido a las autoridades
permanentes para que formalmente inicien
querella criminal tendiente a determinar
quiénes han sido los autores y
partícipes de la mayor administración
fraudulenta y la mayor malversación de
caudales que nuestra memoria recuerda
una deuda tomada por un gobierno
irresponsable que obtuvo un crédito
otorgado en su favor por motivos
absolutamente políticos merece una
revisión y un tratamiento adecuado a la
hora de su renegociación daniela y
pasamos a eeuu que también busca crear
un impuesto a los llamados super ricos
como lo han hecho algunos países de
américa latina como argentina varios
congresistas del partido demócrata
presentaron un proyecto denominado ley
de impuestos a los ultra millonarios
esta legislación establece un impuesto
anual del 2% sobre el patrimonio neto de
quienes tengan fortunas mayores a 50
millones de dólares y hasta mil millones
de dólares y si pasan de ese umbral
habría una sobretasa adicional si se
llegara a aprobar esta medida cobijaría
unas 100.000 personas o sea el 0.05
más rico del país ellos creen que
podrían recaudar unos 3 billones de
dólares en 10 años para que se haga una
idea esto es lo mismo que costó el
primer paquete de ayudas directas de
hace casi un año ahora viene la parte
difícil valentina después de presentarlo
y es que lo aprueben en las dos cámaras
daniela dejamos américa nos vamos a
áfrica porque genera polémica la
construcción de un mega oleoducto bueno
la francesa total y china national
offshore oil corporation comenzarán a
trabajar pronto en un mega oleoducto
entre uganda y tanzania el proyecto
cuesta 3 mil 500 millones de dólares de
los cuales dos terceras partes tendrán
que ser financiadas con deuda pero una
carta abierta firmada por 263
organizaciones benéficas pide a los
grandes bancos que no pongan sus
recursos en el miremos este oleoducto de
casi 1500 kilómetros va desde el oeste
de uganda a través de la vecina tanzania
hasta el puerto de tanga en el océano
índico
estas organizaciones estiman que unas
14.000 familias de estas zonas perderán
tierras porque el proyecto pasa por unas
400 aldeas y advierten del daño
ambiental porque gran parte del tubo
atraviesa la cuenca del lago más grande
de áfrica el lago victoria pero ya hay
un acuerdo firmado por ambos gobiernos
para hacerlo realidad en el que
argumentan que necesitan mover su
petróleo para reactivar la economía
vamos ahora con los indicadores
económicos wall street obtuvo buenas
ganancias con el índice de standard and
poor's marcando su mejor día desde junio
en europa las bolsas también cerraron
positivas porque el rendimiento de los
bonos del tesoro de eeuu comenzó a bajar
y en américa latina hubo alzas
generalizadas en los principales parques
daniela pues muchas gracias por toda
esta información y a ustedes gracias por
su sintonía continúen con nosotros aquí
hay más en france 24
[Música]